thank you
[Music]
so uh as the United States housing
market cools down mortgage mortgage
rates have surged right because uh
interest rates are going up record home
price appreciation has sidelined more
buyers but Goldman Sachs is expecting
home prices will fall 39 up to 39
percent
uh oh I'm sorry we'll we'll fall in 39
of U.S cities next year wow I mean I've
heard this stat
um and there's a graph of like what
cities will be impacted the most yeah a
lot of California cities West Coast
cities
um about Pasadena specifically not
Pasadena does that mean Pasadena is a
good one man good one it's a good hold
as they say
yeah you bought right nope okay cool uh
no so uh
what's your take on the housing market
right now Walter because you're a
homeowner out in LA right not in L.A
they'll see but like Okay so
you have different schools like some
people think oh like housing market like
you know it's gonna drop but it doesn't
say like well maybe it does article does
say like it doesn't say how much the
prices are gonna drop
one thing is rent hasn't dropped rent is
actually increasing which is what is it
should be scary to people that don't
have homes yet
um you're looking at like in Orange
County there's rent like I don't want
the averages but I know rent for like
condos or like as high as 3 500 to 4
000. so that's like it's like if you
save if you like live with your parents
for a little bit and you save money for
down payment so I just get a home
honestly at that point that's if you
want a home but I don't encourage people
that don't want homes to get but then a
down payment in in California is like
hundreds of thousands of dollars though
yes however if you're black or Mexican
right now it's zero because yeah because
of that they're trying to help like like
first-time homeowners prefer homeowners
and there's actually a lot the problem
with that though is you don't have to uh
pay the down payment but then now your
mortgage is crazy high with insurance
right and also it's just crazy high
because you put zero nothing down well
at least it's not predatory is that
another predatory bubble popper why
would they do that
and a lot of people were like you're
masking it as like hey this is for the
communities but in reality you're
setting them up for failure again yeah
because you're just gonna get them to
default so the like black uh not
Blackwater [ __ ] BlackRock or whatever
can come in and swoop it but isn't it
their fault for taking the loan I listen
to Ben Shapiro it's their fault for
taking the loan it's their fault for
taking them they shouldn't even be doing
it at the first place so if you can't
afford it why are you trying to pay for
it
that's up to them they took the loan
they took the risk look at the name Ben
Shapiro what which black can Mexicans
are listening to a guy named Ben Shapiro
if the guy was like Otis Washington
okay oh just Washington he should be
saying something but like yeah if it's
for the community yeah okay dude great
dude no down payment and then do super
low interest rates
like you know and then instead of 30
years making 50 years it might this is
my I heard that there's gonna be like a
40-year loan coming out probably I mean
because Japan is like 50 to 100 Year
loans well Japan's crazy because their
economy hasn't covered recovered since
the 90s and they their [ __ ] interest
rate is like point zero one percent I
looked into the 40 years and all their
real estate is depreciating you looked
in the 40th looked at the 40-year loan
and it's not as awesome as it seems
because uh for them to make money they
add actually additional interest points
oh so like so if it's like five percent
it's like cool now you can have a
40-year loan but now it's like six or
seven percent so the payments aren't
that much cheaper considering you're
adding another decade to your contract
because I heard because you know again I
learned everything from Tick Tock I
heard this one guy I've heard his name
but he was saying they're like you rent
he goes yeah he he's a multi-millionaire
is it thatch
yeah heal
if you don't know what he looks like
um
[Laughter]
he brought up a good point he was like
why do I want to own a home you got to
pay um like okay let's say mortgage and
rent is the same let's just say that but
you got to pay um the interest you got
to pay property taxes oh is it Grant
Cardone I don't know his name he's a
real confident Brash guy very likable is
he like difficult I don't know how tall
he is because they're always sitting
down okay and I'm not an astronomer
right I can't judge those things based
on but there are different schools of
thought like so like you know some
people believe in renting
um and some people believe in owning
depending on their life strategy that's
true because like for example if your
life goal is to just like be in
different cities every year why would
you commit to uh owning a home and tying
up your money that way or like if you're
if you have a business like us you can
write off so much yeah and um well
actually it got capped off because our
former supreme leader decided ten
thousand dollars is the max you can
write off on real estate yeah so
California that's the property taxes any
improvements it exceeds it'll exceed ten
thousand dollars yep so that's that was
a weird thing that especially if he's in
real estate yeah wouldn't he want a
benefit but then he also did cut the
corporate tax rate down to like what 20
something percent like low 20s which
which benefited Wells Fargo tremendously
because they had five billion dollars in
fines for signing up those fake accounts
um oh no I'm sorry they made five
billion Their fines were three billion
and then because of our former Supreme
leaders tax corporate tax cut they made
out with two billion dollars that year
wow interesting so but then but then he
he's the first time they ever made a
under President I heard for sure yeah oh
for sure dude no banks are always for us
yeah that's what I'm hearing you know um
but yeah no it was weird that he dropped
the he capped it off at 10 grand because
other states 10 grand it didn't make
much of a difference because their
property taxes are low but for us
most properties are around 10 grand for
property tax and then once that happens
if you have an improvement you can't
write that off so it's so that becomes
an issue with California Home Ownership
if you want to do multiple Properties or
one property yeah um so then when that
what that guy said on Tick Tock it makes
more sense now because you can't write
everything off that you used to be able
to
um but I was like with rent with rent
increasing because rent has increased
home ownership it's not as appealing and
then with interest rates like higher
than they were but you have to remember
and I think it was early 2000s or
something like that around that time
interest rates are 10 yeah yeah and
pre-2008 that was pretty normal so even
now at five or six percent why it's
still lower than just we're just spoiled
yeah with the last three percent that's
nuts due to something yeah that's not we
have short-term memory when it comes to
like things that are good I want to tell
a low-income family they're spoiled
no but for me they expected out of you
so you know what I mean like like
personally for me I I always feel like
it's funny I'm not the one saying if you
want to help low-income housing like for
me I always think like yeah do no down
payments and do low interest rate and
really help them rather than screwing
them in a secret secretive way
um I always that's what I that's what I
kind of maintain to believe however for
people that are doing it for money and
investing I get it like I I hate to take
away money from someone that's trying to
earn money hopefully in all legal in a
nice way
um because some everyone has to be able
to make money yeah
um but yeah especially the colleges
that's why I think Texas is a Textbook
Company no look paying off the student
loan debts couldn't be more for it
because even though every year all the
tuition costs keep going up let's not
focus on that let's focus on the kids
who are getting the loans I say because
yeah all these big colleges making out
like [ __ ] Bandits nothing seems to be
going up for them it's so funny how that
works right well our teachers that's
what's costing so much Goddamn money you
know professors we gotta yeah we gotta
line these [ __ ] classrooms with gold
is the problem
you know you guys understand how it is
I'm okay I don't need to cut that
[ __ ] [ __ ] we gotta [ __ ] charge the
kids and oh and then we gotta say it's
their fault we're gonna and then we
gotta piss off all the right Wingers
we're like I don't want to pay for
somebody else's loans but then it's like
oh we're not gonna tell the universities
to cut their costs no [ __ ] way ever
because they are the ones who are giving
us all kinds of [ __ ] entitlements
unbelievable how dare they I think
because I think other schools should do
that not USC but I think other states
yeah yeah we should keep raising our two
because you donate to them right
you give them a little stipend over here
they have it they have enough without my
20 bucks exactly
but do they but do they will they ever
have enough it depends who you go up 20
a year I'll put it this way um as soon
as I finished uh when I left school we
got a new president and that President
their goal was we got to raise a billion
dollars
in like 10 years they raised it in like
three or four years so they upped it to
2 billion they raised that in like a
couple years right and then I was like
at that point I didn't give any money
I'm like why why do you mean why do you
need hours how about what do you do with
one billion you tell me what we do with
one billion we'll talk about two yeah
where is it going yeah can we talk like
my parents talk to me have you seen our
football team they spend the money to
keep the surrounding area looking shitty
actually okay I don't know if you how
recently you guys been to USC they've
caucasianized that area so well before
when I was there they told us don't go
south don't go don't go to the Coliseum
only go north okay now you can go
anywhere there's condos there's studio
apartments all around there's there's
like Starbucks there's like restaurants
everywhere and also because our
basketball arena is across the street
you could just walk around anyway so
they made it just nice
so I don't know if the 2 billion or the
three billion they raised went to that I
hope it did but but it's not really USC
unless you have a homeless man jacking
off on a street corner it's not you're
right it's not it's not really L.A it's
not the same exactly you need the Vibes
man you need that little bit of danger
as soon as you go on campus you just
magically feel safe yeah like just one
step on the camera all right you're like
oh yeah I'm on the [ __ ] scene of
Buffy the Vampire Slayer you know it
just feels way chill oh yeah yeah it's
it's funny because it's almost like this
cycle just keeps happening and nothing's
really changed you know it's just it's
gonna get work different con
yeah because you know the one percent
one percent of the one percent they want
to stay wealthy
they don't want to they just they
they're awesome at re repackaging things
yeah to make us be like oh oh and that's
why I think it's really like one of the
I don't want to say key to success but
like a key to like a like a stress-free
living is just living between
all the craziness of the one percent and
then the the craziness of the whatever
the other 99 it's just living between
and you know hopefully we can get by and
survive and be happy and then if we have
the opportunity to help people go for it
you know whether you want to or don't
want to it's up to anything that comes
out where they tailor it specifically
for the poor people is [ __ ] scary to
me it is anything it is I just see no
government you're far when I hear that
yeah I'm just like what's the question
because governments and Banks never work
for charity yeah they never do it in the
goodness of their it's like they're just
corralling them they're not really
telling them like hey here's a [ __ ]
leg up man it's like no we'll keep you
there and the problem with when when
governments get into it right when they
develop a department to help a group
if there's no more groups that need help
what happens to that department yeah
it's in their best interest to grow the
problem so like yeah why is there a
homeless problem that hasn't been solved
but only growing in la oh it's because
of the billionaires in this reason in
that reason not it's because they're
also a part of the Racket and these
government-funded programs if they don't
have any more problems to solve what
happens to their jobs what happens to
all the nice Corner offices that they
have well we pacify ourselves we do this
[ __ ] where it's like you know
um hey it's it's okay that Congress
gives themselves raises every year
because at least my guys in there yeah
right I voted him in doesn't matter it's
my guy that's my guy right there if I
put him on my fantasy team that's my
[ __ ] guy he's gonna give me all the
points this year he's been working hard
yeah he's working hard for me I know he
is I just know it
he's making sure I get tax cuts when I
make the million dollars so I'm not a
million dollars yet but he's making the
tax cut so when I get there and that's
this that's the dream the Republic like
my party the Republican Party sells yeah
is that hey you're gonna be a
millionaire in one day so you we're not
gonna we're gonna raise your taxes right
now but once you become a millionaire
it's gonna be awesome because we've
lowered those taxes already for the
richest richest
owner but they eat it up though they eat
this up they go yeah yeah so they they
constantly go to Republic my party the
Democrat Party what they do so well is
that is there like they're like we got
your [ __ ] back so hard
we need to vote for us in November
and then they're like okay we're in but
like oh man we're gonna need more power
guys this is [ __ ] not gonna work this
is we can't do [ __ ] yet no we promise
that we're gonna cancel your student
debt you have to understand we're only
working with all this power we've we
have an unimpeachable majority we can't
do [ __ ] right now the mental picture of
imagining like a committee of people
going all right the last homeless guy
got himself a home
pleasure working with you let's go man
they just don't quit because they're
[ __ ] done yeah that'd be the weirdest
like that would never happen
foreign